he puts his hand in front of her and
they swap to the puppet oh wow there it
is swap
a well-met cousin they shook hands
and they put a mat i'm still looking for
it and do not see the line yeah i can't
find it either it's flawless
huge thanks to squarespace for
sponsoring today's episode stick around
to the end to see how you can start
building a beautiful website today
hi welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react we are very
excited today we're joined by an amazing
guest john burton jr very experienced
visual effects artist has worked on some
amazing films i started out as a cgi
artist at ilm back at the beginning of
terminator 2 supervising men in black 2
and the 2 mummy movies and so on then i
went independent charlotte's webb was
one who worked on irobot bedtime stories
and new projects netflix shows and
things like that so john's first clip
here is prisoner of zenda which is an
example of early cloning effects and
this is from 1952. yeah let's look at it
stuart granger in a dual role
as the pompous king rudolph and as the
heroic imposter rudolf rasondil this is
like a classic thing right split down
the middle nobody ever crosses the line
right classic parent trap exactly right
so one of the things that you can see in
the best visual effects shots is the
understanding that the audience is on to
your tricks
and so design a shot that proves them
wrong what they did in this movie and is
what you have to do is they say okay we
need a shot that proves we didn't just
do a split screen through it and so they
have them shake hands oh well-met cousin
right there wow
looks pretty good flawless yeah okay
yeah okay
it's so simple and yet it was i i was
looking for a matte line and i did not
see one if you look underneath his
neck on the right where there's the
white line of his shirt and then there's
the collar yeah if you look right there
you will see just this little tiny
movement that his head's not quite
attached to the rest of his body but
that's it you know they took three tries
out and one of them scored they got it
right i'm still looking for it and do
not see the line yeah i can't find it
either it's flawless what they did is
they shook hands
and they put a mat literally a black
piece of paper in the map box of the
camera that blocks off
the part where the stunt double's head
is and they rolled three tanks then they
rewind the camera back to the beginning
of the roll and they did three more
takes with the
mat now only showing his head and they
nailed the stunt doubles shoes to the
floor
position we're not putting down a little
piece of tape to say oh step right here
it's like no
no room for error they these shoes are
nailed to the floor so when when you see
the clips it just goes by there's so
many of these lessons when you look at
something like this and there's all
kinds of things like that you know king
kong is the other example the 1933 one
the technique that is most interesting
is that they're stop mo animating king
kong right that's the base layer of the
shot over here on the right where you
see feyre they photograph fay ray
against this rocky background separately
and what you're looking at here is a
backdrop and stop mo king kong behind
the backdrop is a projector and the
projector is showing a single frame of
feyre against a translucent screen
that's built into the set okay and so
for every frame they animate kong and
they move feyre's clip to the next
framework oh wow and that's how she's
inserted into the into the stop motion
frame all in camera so they're
re-photographing it and what happens now
is that he comes over and picks her up i
think he puts his hand in front of her
and they swap to the puppet oh wow there
it is swap so now
now it's a puppet
that's her in a split i think
with that arm in the background i think
is
a split
wow
she's in a real hand but they're
re-photographing her projected into the
set and then they're matching the
armature of the right and he's pulling
her clothes off to make it
connect the the effect always has to
interact and that's the whole reason
they're doing that is just to sell it
it's like the handshake and prisoner of
zenda so he puts her down and the puppet
now changes back to the film thing so
she gets up she crawls behind the rock
and when she comes out on the other side
she's
a stopmo puppet wow oh yeah because i
can see the shadows from her on the rock
now yeah you know that's the sort of
thing is like you had to figure this all
out ahead of time right yeah so they
escape behind him and they disappear and
they come back and they stop more
puppets wow
dude that was fascinating i love the
idea of also just taking the footage
that they shot
and projecting that onto like a silk
screen to use in camera for the
miniature shot
them being real and putting the shot
that way helps sell the puppet part of
it a little bit better because you're a
little bit more at ease you're not
really looking as hard to be like oh
that's a puppet because you just thought
you were
not it was real and that that's all part
of it and what's cool about it more than
anything to me is i look at this and i
go the people that invented putting blue
screen people on cards think they
invented something
it's already been done they already did
it right
[Music]
one okay
if you want to actually see this done go
check out our show punch for punch over
on netflix's youtube channel still
watching netflix you know my buddy gee
from the stuntman react series well he
took me on a journey where he puts me in
the situation of a pro stunt man and i
have to figure out how to do the
techniques then make a cool little
cinematic short film with what we
learned if you like the reaction you're
gonna love this show go check it out
punch for punch it's on still watching
netflix you're gonna love it check it
out
now were you uh the visual effects
supervisor on men in black i was a
visual effects supervisor in menoblack
ii
i was a computer graphics supervisor on
the first men in black so that meant
that i was participating and shooting it
and then when we went into post it was
my responsibility to make sure that all
the technology was sorted out
looks like you fell off the bus in the
wrong part of town amigo you got this
guy who's an actor and when he cuts him
open now that's a cgi guy holding the
head which is real which was really held
by the the stunt guy that was standing
there mikey when they let you out of
jail
now that is not cgi this
is
rick baker's guy in a suit oh wow and so
this is guy in a suit here and he's
actually holding the head this is now
also a rick baker creation and all this
stuff all the realism of the animation
of the face and all this stuff is coming
out of the guy in a suit so this is a
prosthetic creature like that's a
practical effect but it started off for
one shot there as cgi because then
that's also cg that's cg yes
wow and then the shot right after it's
live action so it just goes back and
forth was what can the guy in the suit
do is the question you're asking as a
visual effects supervisor working with
the director what can the guy in the
suit do until you get to the point where
you need him to do something that the
guy in the suit can't do which is to
take all of his flippers and go
that's too much he didn't have enough
controls there were not enough
animatronics it matches really well it
does and that's because we did lots of
reference so the best reference was to
take the guy in a suit and have him run
through the set okay and then you can
see you can see how the light actually
reflects off the actual guy and that's
what you always match to you're not ever
putting that on the frame but that's a
reality telling you what you need to do
with your synthetic stuff well by the
time we got around to the reference the
fellow that was in the suit john
alexander uh had to go he was off the
clock they said well we need somebody to
run the suit through the set and john
alexander has a very small head so
putting the suit on to somebody became a
problem because
that didn't fit but it fit me
so you got to be the alien for that so i
got so somewhere there's a reference
footage of a guy in blue jeans with the
creature head on no booking through the
sun
once you have the reference you can
effectively once you have your scan the
computer can like look at your color
values with your contrast how you
usually highlight it's all there and the
reason you do that is to get that
reference that shows you what the light
really is on the thing you're really
trying to make
so you are a cg supervisor on men in
black one but you leveled up to an
overall vfx supervisor for men in black
too right boom
spelled my name right too
there was all kinds of crazy stuff in
this movie who are you and how did you
get in here you like egg salad so you
know this stuff here
this took a lot of technique to we had a
giant johnny knoxville foam head really
and he just squished his other head
against it he squished his head against
it which a
gives them the right kind of resistance
and movement on his skin so it looks
like they're actually cheek to cheek and
we had a little head too so we could do
the reverse and it also cast shadows oh
so it put a shadow on the on the
photography so that you when the cg
thing comes in there the shadow's
already cast okay and so you just have
to match it up so for each of these two
heads there are you shooting both plates
of the head on the same day this was
shot the the a side the big johnny
knoxville was shot on the set
on the day with main unit and then the
second head the little head was shot on
a blue screen second unit so now you
have the challenge of matching all of
the lighting and everything around it
right
the question you always have to ask
about chroma screenshots is what do you
shoot first the foreground of the
background
and
well
the answer of course is
it depends
i was like
it's not an answerable question my rule
of thumb is whichever is the
most uncontrollable element
shoot that first big head johnny
knoxville is the most
important part of the shot
they're gonna light him so he looks good
he's gonna give his performance in the
set and all that kind of stuff when we
go to the second unit business we're off
in a blue screen stage
and
we have control over the lighting so
that we can match what we have because
we know what we have because we already
shot it
normally you would shoot the backgrounds
first because then that establishes the
lighting for the blue screen and you can
make the lighting on the blue screen
look right that'd be sort of the ideal
situation but
will smith
is a
very improvisational actor
and he's going to do stuff that you
didn't think of when you were shooting
the background
so you're just going to paint yourself
in a corner so shoot the foreground
first yeah and yeah and then massage the
background into the scene so that you
can give will the opportunity to do
something that barry will like you want
to give him that freedom
you know looking at these shots one of
the things i think is interesting is the
more dimension you put into it the
better it looks it makes it a harder
shot but it looks better because it
doesn't look like it's pasted up that
has got dimension to it and you see
things moving in three-dimensional space
and they actually move in
three-dimensional space because we
actually had johnny knoxville lean into
the camera and so he's moving through
light all that stuff
but when you go to the shots where it's
more flat on like this one it's not as
effective because you don't have that
movement to feel that everything's in 3d
it looks a little bit more pasted on
[Music]
ironically there's no visual effects in
this shot in that shot but
wait is that you wait that is wait
i recognize you you're an alien that's
how i got into the movies
all right there's an interview with rick
baker and he says that he was sitting
with barry sonnenfeld and barry says so
who are we going to get to be the other
alien in the post office
and rick says we need to find somebody
who really looks like they're an alien
[Music]
and so they look around and they go
there he is
oh man i look over and i see barry and
rick looking at me
and i'm like what
and they say you need to go see mary
vote
he's the costumer also a friend of mine
and uh you need to go see mary vote and
i'm like why am i going to the costume
department they said we're putting you
in the scene get out of here
wow there's no vfx in that there's no
vfx in the shot of this shot this is all
rick baker and a hole in the face and a
hole in the floor the whole set is built
this far off the ground okay okay for
just this reason so much work for just
like
a shot yeah and it's over it's huge
production value right there's nothing
repeated it's just more new stuff every
every shot
you know i think jeff that worm is
probably the most complicated one really
exciting sequence and this scene here
was great because all these things with
will smith getting beaned by the the
beam is all choreographed everything's
storyboarded everything's set up and
then you just go out and shoot it and
then you have to put the monster in the
shots of him actually going down the
tunnel is the tunnel itself practical or
is that cg most of it's photography okay
then some of us blue screen but these
tunnel receding that's photography okay
okay so we we actually had a track in
new york where the second unit went in
and shot all this stuff you know some of
this stuff you know it's a little bit
over the top but you get away with it
because it's a comedy right and and that
that's part of the aesthetic of the film
this was kind of one of those
interesting decisions about how to
achieve a certain kind of an effect they
wanted will to be up in the air being
thrashed around by this beast i
suggested that they put up a giant
bungee cord net that was like 20 feet
tall and 20 feet wide this great big
thing and then we let him crawl over it
so he could crawl up on it and he was on
a wire so they could pull them off and
all that kind of stuff he's wrestling
with foam core there's a blue foam
noodle okay
he holds up the end and he goes no
biting and then he he bites into the
foam noodle which was not in the script
and it's great it's a great little thing
see there he was holding onto the net
but we've put the creature where the net
is so that it looks like he's holding
onto the creature anything to make
interaction that's absolutely right
that's super important and especially
when you've got people fighting against
each other you just can't have people
swinging in the air and they people
still do it and it still looks bad
but
all you need is somebody there to hold a
big iron bar up there so when you strike
a sword it hits something you paint out
the guy with the iron bar absolutely and
you've got all the muscles are doing the
right thing the the stop is exactly
right you're not i mean some actors say
oh you know i can stop my arm so it
looks real but you can't send that
shiver down your down your arm that
happens when you actually hit something
yeah you cannot act a shock wave yeah
it's funny like you know we always think
about cgi and visual effects as being
this great new tool to add things to the
shop but as you mentioned like the
ability to paint things out
really also revolutionized a lot of
stuff and a really big example of that
is wire work like wire work took on such
a renaissance with the ability to paint
out wires yeah yeah and now you have
like all the crazy marvel superhero
stuff which owes a lot of its visual
style and action style to the ability to
simply remove wires yeah yeah yeah just
the ability to remove a wire totally
changed like in brought back wires yeah
that were previously only used for very
specialty things in film
brandi o'daniel here reporting live from
the corridor digital studio where i'm
here to ask people today about the best
way to start a website for a small
business courtesy of today's sponsor
squarespace
hi
brandi o'daniel how are you
what are your thoughts on the best way
to get beautiful award-winning templates
for a small business website squarespace
that's correct great answer all right
we're just going to step inside here
oh
there's no one here
wait does anyone even work around here
this is weird
nico how important is it that a website
for your company
has a multiple contributors tool which
allows other people from your company to
do different things on the website you
know that's a great question because if
you want to grow as a company you're
going to need to delegate and spread out
the workload the only way to do that is
with multiple contributors
great answer nothing further thank you
what if i told you that squarespace has
24 7 award-winning customer service wow
i didn't know they gave awards for
customer service so it must be pretty
good
exactly
hey um
would you say that something like
analytics would be important to
understanding your audience i think so i
think it's it's crucial well what if i
told you that squarespace has incredible
traffic overviews tools that allow you
with some of the best in the game
analytics to understand who's coming to
your website what they're doing and how
they're utilizing your website so you
can better craft it for them that'd be a
good thing for you right yes i think so
do you own like land or what's the deal
all right well you heard it here first
uh the best way to get your own website
up and running is with squarespace uh
sir you sir if people are interested in
getting started for themself building a
website uh where should they head to if
it were me i'd go to squarespace.com
corridor crew that's squarespace.com
corridor crew or just click the link
below
thanks for watching everybody i hope
you're having a great day brandi
o'daniel signing off
filmmaking in cinema is illusion right
yeah and
to me visual effects is sort of the
ultimate expression of that particular
artistic
idea show me something i can't see in
reality
show me something on the screen that i
can only experience when i'm watching a
movie
and that's where visual effects really
shines
we're trying to find ways to make
pictures that are astonishing and
amazing that no one's ever seen before
and may never see except within our
artistic exercise so that's it you know
that keeps them going
john it's been honestly an absolute
privilege to have you join us here my
pleasure tell us your stories break
things down give us your philosophies
like you dropped a lot of wisdom for us
and for everybody watching and i really
appreciate you taking the time
my pleasure well we gotta have you back
yeah thank you for watching and we'll
see you next time